It's three years since she died.
Time goes too fast.
Not fast enough.
Why isn't your son here?
Did I do something wrong?
No, but sometimes, it's not easy to be your son.
You're living in the past!
Yesterday, wasn't so great!
Another quick and easy win for Mason Dixon...
...and the crowd is angry!
Maybe next time, Dixon will choose a real opponent.
But is there anyone out there?
You need respect.
You need to test yourself in the ring.
You need a hard fight.
And then, you will have the only kind of respect you need.
You will have respect for yourself.
Mason Dixon heard about your license.
He'd like to do something with you.
An exhibition match.
I want to do something.
I want to fight again.
It's a different world now, Dad.
Time catches all of us.
Time only catches you if you stand still.